it's Wednesday and that means we're
under two weeks away from e3 make sure
you subscribe to so you can see all of
our coverage and hey you can grab the
game spot now app on iOS right now or
Android this Thursday that's enough of
that let's get started I've got good
news for Steven universe fans a Paper
Mario like RPG based on the cartoon is
coming to ps4 and Xbox one Steven
universe save the light is being
developed by grumpy face the studio
behind many of Cartoon Network's recent
mobile titles and fans of the show will
be happy to hear that series creator
Rebecca sugar has worked closely with
the developers the game is a direct
sequel to the mobile game attack the
light in which Steven and the crystal
gems must protect the ancient gem weapon
called the prism from a mysterious new
warrior you'll be able to team up with
other major characters from the series
including Connie and Greg the latter of
whom will serve as a bard and buff your
party by playing songs on his guitar
you'll also be able to increase the bond
between your seven party members to
unlock new skills and even fuse certain
characters together in battle the battle
system is similar to Paper Mario in that
well termed button presses will increase
the amount of damage inflicted by your
attacks Steven universe save the light
will release digitally with no concrete
release date set Cartoon Network have
said that they will reveal more
information including a new
never-before-seen Steven universe
character soon if you can't wait head on
over to GameSpot where you can check out
twenty minutes of gameplay
it seems we all got it wrong on over
watches new teased it's not a new hero
named Hammond it's a map on the moon the
horizon lunar colony is now available on
the public test realm on PC it's an
assault map set on the scientific moon
base where Winston the scientist /
gorilla was raised over watch Game
Director Jeff Caplan had a chat about
the map noting the high ground options
for both teams and the inclusion of low
gravity he noted that low gravity will
be offered in a small portion of the map
and not the full map as it felt like a
gimmick that broke the game but for
those of you who want to give it a shot
anyway there will be a limited time
low-gravity option coming to arcade that
will enable low gravity on all maps
horizon lunar colony will release on PC
ps4 and Xbox one sometime soon
with all these leaks happening in the
video game industry you'd think it was
BP was running it and there's been
another one it seems Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite roster has been leaked Neoga
forum user rice who has a solid record
of leaking Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
details posted the list which is a
mixture of mainstays and newcomers for
both companies obviously there's a lot
so I'm going to list them
like the end of a political ad Capcom
Arthur Chris Chumbley Dante fiber and
cheddar monster Hannah Morrigan nemesis
Ryu Spencer strata haru and ex marbled
Ant Man Captain America Captain Marvel
Doctor Strange Gamora Hawkeye Hulk Iron
Man Nova rocket / Groot is unclear if
it's rocket racoon with grid assisting
or a redesign character actually called
rocket / group spider-man Thanos Thor
Ultron
it's pretty clear that the Marvel site
is leveraging the popularity of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe a series
mainstays like the x-men including
Wolverine Magneto and Sentinel are
absent let me know what you think of the
roster in the comments below Marvel vs.
Capcom Infinite will release on
September 19 for ps4 Xbox one and PC
that's games won't news for today have
yourselves a lovely day and Jess and I
will be back tomorrow so we'll see you
then